[Music]
right now the advent of better and
better information tools is having a
contracting effect where more and more
the economy's being made efficient in
this way that concentrates the wealth of
those who make it efficient I mean just
think about the day that all those
cabbies out-there lose their job because
their cars are driving themselves what
are they going to do and I think they'll
be happy but whoever does that will
become very very rich you know so
whoever whoever is whoever owns the top
server and then big efficiency making
exercise becomes very very rich so
there's this huge concentration even as
the overall economy is shrunk as a
result so the evaluation of Facebook is
just completely normal given the way
information technology is being
integrated into the society and it's not
the last it'll this will just keep on
happening until we realize that it's not
sustainable and there's nothing wrong
with Facebook being treated as valuable
the only problem is that it should be
increasing value for everybody I'm going
to use a different company as an example
an old less fashionable one is just
Walmart so Walmart was one of the
pioneers of using computer networks to
make the world efficient for consumers
anyway Walmart in the 80s and 90s
started to develop its own version of
digital networking especially in the 90s
to precisely calibrate who to buy from
at the best price where to ship it
exactly when and how to ship it and how
to stock it and at which store when I
mean this whole incredible system and as
the result of that it was able to look
to offer lower prices to its customers
that everybody said yeah lower prices
but the thing is it became so big so
fast which is what happens when you do
digital networking yeah it kind of took
over the world and changed its own
environment to make the whole
environment of retailing consumer goods
and creating them more efficient in this
certain way that impoverished its own
comfort customer base so all of a sudden
it's very own customers have fewer job
prospects all of a sudden its customer
pay its customer base gets poorer and
now it's kind of dug itself into this
road where Walmart is no longer
you know as exciting a retailer as it
was because what's it gonna do and it's
trying to sort of climb up scale but it
can't because its customer base can't
support it so to me
Facebook is essentially Walmart for new
generation but Facebook is saying 3d
service is free social networking free
and everything yeah it's free but then
the problem with that is that the job
prospects for the vast majority of
people are actually gradually decreasing
as less and less stuff is monetized so
what you want to do to have an
information based economy and preserve
capitalism is to monetize more and more
of the world instead of less and less of
the world because you want the market to
be growing instead of shrinking but the
problem of the Facebook approach is its
monetizing less and less because they
know all this is free your reward for
participating is reputation karma
connections and all those things are
very real but they're not monetized
they're not securable you can't get a
house mortgage based on your facebook
reputation what I would do is I'd turned
into this commerce platform so that
people can send money around for things
and then I gradually start to adjust it
so people are monetizing more and more
so people can put up their art to sell
to others either with a Kickstarter type
of a thing
or an app store kind of a thing it
doesn't you know it would have to be
tweaked I found exactly the right model
but I would start to turn it into real
commerce so that people who are good at
using Facebook start to make some money
and the economy overall starts to expand
instead of contract as a result of its
existence and I think that's a happier
outcome it would be better for Facebook
that we'd create a better return for
Facebook's investors in the long term
even in the short term
you